- All right, Grace.
So ideally we can recognize
when we are attacked,
but let's say we begin to fall for it.
Let's say there's a
phishing attack and we go,
we click really fast
cause we're all panicked.
We type in our password
and they're like, oh wait,
I think I just gave my
password to a shady site.
What do you do once you're
compromised in some way?
- It's a great question, Sal.
Now this is really unfortunate.
We hope this doesn't happen to folks,
but if it does, there are
a few steps you can take
to help mitigate the fallout
from this kind of phishing attack.
You should immediately tell
a trusted adult, a teacher,
or a parent, and let them know
that this happened to you.
This will also help them make others aware
that if they are hearing
from you on that account
that's been compromised,
so that other folks don't fall
into the same hands of the scammer.
This will also help you take steps
to report the scam if possible.
So, for example, if you're using Gmail,
there is a reporting
tool within your email.
Oftentimes you can get
alerts on your phone
if there are phone calls
that look like a scam,
but there are also ways
that you can report that.
So definitely work with a trusted adult
if you think that this
has happened to you.
And then once you've kind
of mitigated the fallout
from that, you can look at
best practices to make sure
that that password isn't
compromised in other places.
So you are going to want
to update that password,
enroll in two step verification
as we talked about,
and make sure that on a regular basis
you're changing your password.
So even if this happens to you
and you weren't made aware,
you can actually mitigate
some of that risk
if you're updating and
having strong passwords
on a frequent basis.
There's another nifty tool
called Security Checkup
that can actually help you
check on your passwords
for all of your accounts where
you use your email to log in.
And that helps you keep
track and make sure
that you know your
passwords aren't outdated
or you know, worst case scenario
that they haven't been breached
in some kind of data breach
or a phishing attempt.
- Super, super useful.